madam deputy speaker
i have one final announcement that
exemplifies
the future economy a policy on a scale
we've never done before a policy to
bring investment trade
and most importantly jobs right across
this country
to replace the industries of the past
with green
innovative fast-growing new businesses
to encourage free trade and reinforce
our position
as an outward-looking trading nation
open to the world
a policy we can now only pursue now that
we are
out of the european union free ports
free ports are special economic zones
with different rules to make it easier
and cheaper
to do business they're well established
internationally
but we're taking a unique approach our
free ports
will have simpler planning to allow
businesses to build
infrastructure funding to improve
transport links
cheaper customs with favorable tariffs
vat
or duties and lower taxes with tax
breaks to encourage construction
private investment and job creation
an unprecedented economic boost across
the united kingdom freeports will be a
truly uk-wide policy
and we will work constructively with the
scottish welsh
and northern irish administrations today
i can announce the eight freeport
locations
in england east midlands airport
felix doe and harrich humber
liverpool city region plymouth
solent thames and t side
eight new free ports in eight english
regions
unlocking billions of pounds of private
sector investment
generating trade and jobs up and down
the country i commend members from
across the house
for their campaigning but in particular
the honourable members
for red car clee thoughts and great
grimsby
as well as inspiring local leaders like
ben houchen the mayor
for teas valley